What are more common in high dimensional
spaces? Local minima or saddle points?
It’s tempting to think it is the local minima,
because they are often problematic in
machine learning (at least in theory).
However, the right answer to this AI
Coffee Break Quiz is “saddle points”.
In a nutshell: To tell local minima from saddle
points apart, we look at the Hessian matrix,
which is sort-of the second derivative
of a function, like the loss function,
that takes as input a vector and outputs a scalar.
For a local minimum, the Hessian
has only positive eigenvalues,
for a saddle point it has a mixture
of positive and negative eigenvalues.
Now think about it: what is more likely
to happen? To have exclusively n positive
eigenvalues in an n-dimensional space? Or a
mixture of both negative and positive signs?
Well, because a mix is more likely,
saddle points are more likely to occur.
They come with small gradients in their vicinity,
making gradient-based optimization harder.